De gör mig bättre.
Varje gång jag får ett brev av dem så gör de mig bättre.
Och så länge de fokuserar på att försvåra för oss så fokuserar vi på att komma framåt.
För de lägger sin tid fel, de borde fokusera på att göra bättre och lägre.
Make Sweden Stronger.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger...
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Välkomna, vi är Filippa Lagerstedt från Bämis.
Jag har precis plöjt igenom en treåring och en femåring här i deras utvecklingsfaser och bytt x antal blöjor under flera år.
Jag har fascinerats över hur kopiösande blöjor man köper.
Titt halva våran soptitt är ju blöjor hemma.
Det är en absurd skillnad.
Bämis säljer ju blöjor framförallt.
Filippa, var det det som fick dig att börja tänka på?
Att blöjor var någonting konstigt.
Nej, man tänker ju inte på blöjor innan man får barn.
Det är väl precis när man kommer ut från BB som första gången man har satt på en blöja på ett barn.
Eller i alla fall så var det för mig.
Och jag tror att idén kom när min son fick ganska mycket blöjexcem.
Då började jag börja tänka på blöjor.
Innan hade jag inte tänkt på alls.
Men när han fick blöjexcem, då gör man ju research som förälder.
Så fort det var stora skillnaden med att ens få barn var väl egentligen hur mycket man började googla om grejer.
För att man kan ju ingenting.
Jag har gett min fru förbud mot att hänga på familjeliv.
Från ett år innan barnen föddes, så sa jag att jag lägger mig inte i en bil.
Vi har liksom ungefär samma syn på allting.
Men du får inte gå in på familjeliv.
Det är det enda vetot jag kommer ha under hela vårt hållande.
Men i övrigt absolut, man kör ju researchspåret.
Vad kom du fram till?
Nej men det som jag kom fram till då var väl att det var mycket plast i blöje.
När man googlar, vad är innehållet i en blöja?
För jag hade faktiskt ingen aning om vad det var i en blöja, innan jag började googla.
Och det kanske var dumt men jag fick en chock när jag såg att det var typ 75-80% plast i blöjor.
Det är inte jättesvårt att fatta vad det är som ger blöjxc.
För barn kissar och bajsar hela tiden i början och det stängs in i den där plasten.
Man fattar ju att det inte är jättebra.
Det var det som gjorde att jag började försöka se vad finns det för andra typer av alternativ.
På den svenska marknaden fanns nästan ingenting.
Vad är alternativ?
Man har ju sett så här folk som försöker att börja skocka ner en sån här tyg-glöja.
Det var så här att det inte kommer hända att jag tvättar bajs i min rättsmaskin.
Det är liksom för mäckigt.
Jag som nästan alltid är på språng någonstans, jag kan inte täcka att jag ska ta med mig tyg-blöjor.
Det fanns inte på kartan för mig.
Jag testade alla blöjor som fanns på den svenska marknaden, men tyckte att det var lite saksamma.
Det var ändå samma produkt men olika brands.
Men jag började kolla på Amazon och var såhär, gud det finns ju super mycket i USA.
Varför finns det blöjor av bummel där, det finns i bambu där, det finns i oljefri plast, det finns variationer av plast och andra material.
Där fanns det en helt annan marknad.
Vad är anledningen till det?
Jag tänkte väl att det är en mycket mycket större marknad och den ligger före ganska många konsumentprodukter, ofta och trender.
Men jag tror att blöjor är inte riktigt en trend, utan det är ju någonting som man alltid kommer behöva använda.
Men vad jag tänkte var väl att det är en större marknad, det finns plats för fler aktörer.
Men jag började inte riktigt i den änden, utan jag började det för att säga så här, okej men är de här blöjorna lika bra då?
Om det finns växtbaserade blöjor, är de lika bra som en blöjor plast?
För att annars tycker inte jag att det går att göra.
Annars duger det inte ändå för att ska det bli en läcka eller liksom så, då kommer du inte använda den ändå även fast den är bättre.
Jag beställde väl typ allt som fick att beställa på Amazon hem och hittade en som jag tyckte var så sjukt bra och fick bort exemen för min son.
Så det var ju de jag körde under perioden med honom.
Det kan man ju så här ur en hållbarhetssynpunkt.
Det är jävligt dåligt att sitta och köpa blöder därifrån för de behövde ju liksom skickas hit och det var jättedyrt men samtidigt så var det så här jag gillade dem.
Men då kom ju idén att så här, varför ska det här inte få finnas i Europa?
Varför kommer de inte hit?
Och jag skulle väl kanske gjort mer analys än att bara du vet sätta igång direkt och börja jobba med det för att jag har nu fattat nu kanske varför det inte finns fler.
Varför finns det inte fler?
Vad är liksom svårigheten?
Alltså konkurrensen är så tuff med de två stora jätterna som finns.
Och de har ju liksom otroliga muskler och de är så etablerade.
Och jag tror inte ens typ föräldrar reflekterar överblöjer för det är ju så vanligt att du bara köper liksom de märkena och allt är väldigt kampanndrivet.
Det är en väldigt prispressad produkt.
Så jag tror att det är många grejer som man kanske hade fattat om man hade gjort lite mer analys innan man satte igång.
Men så gjorde inte jag.
Utan jag var mer att börja jobba fram vår produkt så som jag ville ha den.
Vart vänder du dig då?
Okej, om man ska köpa in smycken i Kina eller något sånt där eller om man har sig i Pallibaba, hur får man igång blöjor?
Jag, helt ärligt så googlade jag bara.
Jag började med en googling.
How to make diapers.
Ja typ.
Alltså det, eller blöjfabrik.
Vart hittar jag en blöjfabrik?
Och då kom jag ju in på liksom, några av de stora fabrikerna och vart de producerar sina blöjor och så.
Jag bara, men jag fattade ju ganska fort att de kommer inte att producera mina blöjor, så jag måste ju hitta en egen fabrik.
Och ville ha dem i bambu, för det var det som hade funkat.
Kom in på några, såhär i Turkiet fanns det några.
Det fanns i Kina såklart eftersom det är där all bambu växer och faktiskt där vi producerar.
Men jag testade ju liksom, jag tror jag testade en, säkert mellan 50 och 100 fabriker.
Jag satt varje vecka och beställde sam-pass och testade för mitt barn.
För det var ju såhär, jag hade ju en testdocka hemma, så jag kunde ju prova både hur de läckte, hur huden såg ut, liksom passform och så vidare.
Sen tog ju jag faktiskt splayor härifrån, som jag gillade mest i mina favoritbrands.
Och när jag väl hade hittat en fabrik som jag tyckte höll mina mått, och så var jag såhär, nu vill jag att ni tar fram samples på typ en liknande passform, de här, men helt i bambu, mot huden.
Det får inte vara någon plast mot huden.
Och jag vill ha så lite, lite plast som möjligt.
Jag vill att ni tar bort plasten ur förpackningen, jag vill att ni försöker ta bort plasten i teipen.
Jag vill att ni liksom, för då kommer jag att bli er kund.
Och de gjorde faktiskt det.
För det här var en lite mindre fabrik, som bara jobbade med ekoprodukter, engångsartiklar.
Så jag antar att de såg att potentiellt så kanske vi kan bli en större kund i framtiden.
Och det är ju fortfarande de jag jobbar med, och de har ju blivit som en extra familj.
Alltså jag pratar med dem så ofta och jag var där i våre och hälsade på dem, och det kändes som att såhär, wow.
Alltså det var så härligt att träffa dem.
Dels undrar jag, vad är det som är just bambu?
Varför är det det viktiga?
Spelar det någon roll om tejpen är i plast eller inte?
Varför drar man gränsen?
Jo, absolut.
Jag har alltid sagt att jag utgår från att performance är fortfarande det absolut viktigaste.
Så att kommer den ta på performance, då tar jag inte det alternativet.
Men bambu var det viktigaste för mig mot huden.
För bambu i sig är ett material som är antibakteriellt, det är extremt mjukt.
Det är också ett material som inte typ, eller det är råvaror som du inte behöver arbeta med över huvud taget, utan den växer av sig självt.
Den växer liksom, den växer som ogräs, alltså den kan växa upp till en meter per dag.
Det är en otrolig råvara och den kan liksom, den kan växa på mark som också redan är förstörd av övergödning eller torka.
Bambu kan nästan växa överallt.
Så det är en väldigt snäll planta.
Behöver ingen konstbevattning eller så.
Det var det som man också tyckte var extra bra med det.
För annars som du gör i bomull eller något, så är det ganska mycket process med det.
Och bambu är nästan ingenting.
Så det var väl liksom den främsta anledningen.
Men framförallt för känslan är att det är som gjuts.
Och jag tänker med, ibland så kan man ha bambu typ strumpor, man kan ha det i underkläder, träningskläder, just för att det är ett material som andas.
Och i en blöja så är det en väldigt trevlig egenskap att materialet andas.
Så det var väl liksom därför.
Om vi kallar det för någon standardblöja då, vad är det som gör att de inte kör i bambu?
Eller varför är plast den stora?
Om vi helt skiter i att det stänger in eller inte, eller varför är plast det?
Jag tror varför de inte har gjort det.
Jag tror alltid att det är när en marknad är, vad ska man säga, när den har stått still.
Det är två konkurrenter typ, och dagligvaruhandelsägna märken.
Det hämmar innovation lite grann, när det inte kommer in nya spelare.
För att de som sitter där är fat and happy med de grejer de gör.
De tjänar extrema mängder pengar på den produkten de redan har.
Och skulle de behöva, skulle de släppa en bambulinje eller en sån produkt, då skulle de behöva för det första investera ganska mycket pengar i det.
Och de skulle behöva ge uppmärksamhet till det området och skulle på något sätt, jag skulle säga att det är svårt att säga att plast är bättre än bambu.
Så det hade blivit en blöja som de hade behövt säga är bättre än den andra som de säljer, som är deras bästsäljare och där de får alla sina pengar.
Så jag tror att skulle de göra det så skulle de skära ner där grenarna de sitter på.
Jag kan inte sådär as mycket om blöjor världen över, men finns det något land där det som vi känner som standardblöja är standardblöjan?
Finns det något land som har bambublöjer som standard?
Nej, jag tror tyvärr att det är lite för dyrt att ha dem i de länderna där bambun växer, vilket jag tycker är synd.
Men jag tror att det börjar bli, om man läser på nu hur den här, om man ska kalla det en trend, eller att det är på väg bort ifrån, att många är på väg att ditcha platsen.
Att man kan se, till exempel USA som är en marknad som ligger före Åstad, de har haft växtbaserade blöjor sen 2016, de är inne på sig tionde år med det.
Där ser man att det ökar, att det ökar mycket varje år på att föräldrar byter bort de vanliga traditionella blöjorna och byter till de nya märkena som börjar komma som har det här växtbaserade, eller prenumerationstjänst, eller liksom, vad ska man säga, man köper i stor pack.
När jag var i USA förra året så gjorde jag värsta analysen av det.
Det finns inte en affär som säljer ett blöjpaket i USA.
För du använder inte ett blöjpaket.
Du använder ju som du sa i början.
Man använder upp till 200 blöjor.
I början är det liksom 250 blöjor i månaden.
Det är extrema mängder som man använder.
Så jag tror att de börjar gå åt det hållet.
Så där de växtbaserade alternativen, de bolagen börjar bli stora.
Så jag tror att snart så.
För det handlar ju lite grann om pris då.
Eller det låter som det handlar om pris.
Hur mycket dyrare är en bambublöja än en vanlig blöja?
Det är ju så svårt för blöjor är en jättejobbig kategori.
För det är ju olika priser oavsett vilken butik du är i.
För blöjor är någonting som handlar i kampanjer för att locka in barnfamiljer.
Men generellt sett skulle jag säga att det är typ en krona dyrare per blöja.
Och vad kostar en blöja?
Typ två, tre kronor.
Okej, så det är någonstans 30-50 procent dyrare.
Det är det på våra småstolikar.
Jag skulle säga på våra byxblyeg, som man kommer högre, som man hör när man har lite större barn.
Då kostar de typ samma.
Så det är också lite olika prisstrategier som vi håller också på att testa hur vi ska ta betalt.
Men jag tror att de stora märkena gör att de ger väldigt billigt i början.
Så att man ska fastna för deras produkter.
Och sen så höjer de priset successivt när man är inkörd.
Och det är ganska smart att göra så.
Men vi är i dagsläget som är i början av vårt resa.
Vi kan inte gå bak på produkter på samma sätt.
Kan du berätta lite om era resa?
Ni är relativt tidiga inne.
Ni har väl valt på i två år i september.
Med allt som allt.
Så det är absolut tidigt.
Det är fortfarande bara jag i bolaget är ihop med Penny, som är Penny Panevik som jag driver ihop med.
Men vi har väl liksom valt den takten egentligen.
Att vi växer på organiskt.
Genom att få fler återförsäljare och få finnas på flera hyllor.
Och jag tror att det började ju egentligen när jag hade den här färdiga produkten.
De var jättenöjna med den.
Och tänkte såhär, vi kör en e-handel.
För jag har ingen erfarenhet av resor överhuvudtaget.
Vad är din bakgrund?
Det är marknadsföring.
Jaha okej, om du har så.
Men jag har aldrig jobbat med en fysisk produkt, utan jag har antingen jobbat med tjänster eller...
Innan jag började med det här så jobbade jag på hotelldiplomat och villa Dagmar.
Som marknadschef liksom.
Så det var ju en helt annan produkt, att sälja hotellrum, lyxig hotellrum istället för blöjor.
Men jag hade ingen erfarenhet av det.
Jag handlade på en butik här i Nacka där jag bor, och jag ville ha in dem här.
Så jag måste se vad jag ska göra.
Så jag frågade ju bara någon i butiken vem det är som är ansvarig för blöjor.
Och där fick jag träffa en fantastisk kille som hette Joel.
Nu är det jättekul.
Jävla bra honom.
Han träffade mig ut i butiken och var, du vet jag stod där med min bebis då som var två veckor gammal.
Jag vill ha mina blöjor här, hur ska jag göra?
Men måste detta vara barn nummer två?
Ja det var barn nummer två.
Ja exakt, jag fick inte ihop timelineen här.
Nej jag fick ett barn där emellan, det var en ny bebis.
Och han var såhär, kom med, jag har 20 minuter, kom med på kontoret.
Och då berättade han hur hela ICA funkar.
Han beskrev sin butik som ICA's Bianca en Grosso, att tar vi in det så tar resten av butikerna i Sverige in det.
Attityd han ville ha.
Jag tror han förhandlade också, för han kunde sätta de friser han ville ha om han tog in.
Och sen var han såhär, okej men du har en jävla grej Filippa, för du kommer här och ger oss 30 procent på att blöja, 30 procent på marginal.
Vi går bak på att blöja.
Och jag bara, aha, det hade varit bra för mig att veta det innan, för då hade jag inte tagit i så schysst marginal.
Det här kommer vara en fördel för dig, för alla kommer vilja prova.
Vi är trötta på att det ser ut såhär, att det tar upp mycket plats i butikerna och vi tjänar inga pengar.
Och det var liksom så i början, för då gav han mig en lista på de butiker som han tyckte att jag skulle köra de här butikerna och sen gå ut i ICA centralt.
Och jag följde hans råd och gjorde det och hade av mig till ICA centralt och liksom när vi hade funnits i sju månader så tog de in oss.
Vad innebär det?
Det låter ju som att man har gjort någon sorts breakthrough, man har vunnit igår.
Ja, inom retail.
Man trodde det i början.
Att nu är vi hemma typ, fast man ändå fattade att det inte var så.
Men det var jätteviktigt för oss.
För att innan behövde vi betala alla frakter ut till varje butik.
Vi behövde se till att de fyllde på ordentligt.
Man hade inte alls den här tryggheten i att kunna säga att ICA redan accepteras vara produkter.
Jag var tvungen att pitcha för varenda ICA-handlare varför de skulle ha mina produkter.
Det är underlätt att sälja betet, otroligt att vara inne där.
Då kan man bara säga att du beställer bara hem hos ICA, så kommer jag till din butik.
De vet att allt är okej med oss som leverantör.
Det är en trygghet för dem att köpa via ICA istället för att köpa av ett enskilt bolag.
Det var bra, men samtidigt är det så att du kommer in dit och får ha den här varor där de sätter in en i planogrammen.
Man får ett visst antal skjuts ut i ett visst antal butiker.
Men sen måste man fortfarande hela tiden kontinuerligt jobba med att få in nya butiker.
Man måste se att det rullar från hyllorna.
Man måste köra en del kampanjer.
Man måste bearbeta dem helt enkelt.
Så det är inte så att man bara kan chilla efter man är inne där, utan snarare att det är då det börjar.
Kan du ta oss med lite på hur utvecklingen har sett ut under de två åren?
Inte månad för månad, men var det någon som köpte första månaden?
Ja, jag skulle säga att i början när man lanserar ett nyttvarumärke som ingen vet vad det är, och framförallt i en sån här kategori, då är det så lärt att det var vänner.
För det var de som såg det.
Och innan man hade någon ens budget.
Det här gjorde jag själv, med min pappa.
Och bara startade någonstans.
Men i början, jag kommer ihåg när vi fick vår första Ica Max i butik, det var ju den han i nacka i, yes nu har vi en Ica butik.
Vi fick en jättestor hyllplats, har jag fattat nu också.
Så det var så här, han var verkligen schysst.
Men sen gick det fort.
De första typ fyra månaderna, om vi säger att vi lanserade i september.
Och innan året var slut så hade vi i alla fall 30 butiker.
Så det gick ändå fort och då var det liksom jag som åkte runt med min bebis och sålde in.
Och jag åkte ju till de här butikerna hela tiden för att titta på hyllorna.
Är det folk som tar mina paket?
Och det var det.
Och sen började det de här online apoteken.
Att jag fick höra från branschkollegiet att det är det bästa, vi säljer så bra där och det är så som är ditt.
Började kontakta dem och då tog alla dem inom apotia och meds och av på hem och mat hem och allt det kom igång.
Och sen, vad blir det?
Då hade vi allt på ett halvår.
Och jag tyckte väl att vi omsatte helt okej.
Jag tyckte att det var typ 70-80 000 i månaden.
Det var okej för att vara hemma och bara vara föräldraledig med mitt barn.
Men sen så var det såhär, om jag ska kunna lämna mitt jobb och köra på det här, så måste jag säga upp mig och då måste jag ta in mer kapital för att allt som vi gör just nu behöver gå in till nye varor.
Så det kändes väl som nästa steg.
Jag var lite kluven till det också för att jag gillar ju att få bestämma själv.
Jag gillar att få styra själv och var lite rädd för hur det skulle bli om jag tog in något annat.
Men då kom jag i kontakt med Fem Invest, som var för tjejer.
Jag träffade några härliga ängelinvesterare som kunde hjälpa mig första året.
Då tog vi in två miljoner kanske.
Det hjälpte mig till kommande år och då kunde vi gasa på lite mer.
Sedan kom vi med i Draknästet under samma period.
Jag fick ingen investering där, för de tyckte att det var för tidigt.
Jag hade hållit på i sex månader, det måste behövas lite till.
Samtidigt som jag kände att jag kommer inte att behöva hjälp sen.
Så att ska ni vara med så är det nu.
Jag sa faktiskt det lite grann för att jag var inte beredd på att gå med på vilken värdering som helst.
Jag kunde gå med om jag kunde få den värderingen som jag ville ha.
Jag hade redan säkrat de andra pengarna, men det var bra marknadsföring för där fick jag mer penny.
Det är det bästa som har hänt här i bolaget.
Att få med både henne som profil men också som person.
Hon gör ju allting med mig nu.
Att få in den där extra partnern är otroligt viktigt.
När du säger att det var det bästa, jag menar inget illa mot henne, men vad gör hon på riktigt?
När jag menar det, så menar jag vad hon gjorde med mig faktiskt.
För att jag fick en helt ny syn på det och den här boosten jag behövde.
För att det enda jag fick höra på varje möte jag satt med de här stora butikerna var, har du budget till det här?
Har du marknadsföring till det här?
För nu ser jag hur mycket de andra håller på.
Jag bara, ja, det var det jag sa innan.
Men sen när jag hade med mig Penny, så fattade de att hon är väldigt stor, som en mamma-profil.
Då började väl de lita på oss som leverantör också, att de kommer försöka marknadsföra skiten av det här på sitt sätt.
Okej, är det så det funkar?
Ni måste, jag bara funderar på vad du använder pengarna till.
Det är inte så mycket lagensats som ni använder till, utan det är marknadsföring eller vad är det?
Ja, lager också.
Vi använder ju, det är en ganska stor post i vårt, för att förvara våra produkter, för det är rätt jobbigt att blöja och ta sjukt mycket plats.
Och vi har ju också en e-handel, och de sköter vår tredjeparts logistik.
Men det är ju en ganska dyr post.
Men jag skulle säga att det är framförallt marknadsföring, om vi ska köpa nya produkter, marknadsföring och lager.
Det är de tre grejerna som kostar.
Vad snurrar bolaget idag, nu typ två år senare?
Ja, vi räknar med att omsätta det här året, alltså runt 4,5 miljoner kanske.
Det går väl såhär sakta men säkert framåt.
Du som också är entreprenör, man är ju alltid långt framåt och vill att det ska gå mycket snabbare än vad man tycker att det gör.
Alltså, menas folk utomstående tycker att det går fort, men att man själv säger att det går inte fort.
Ja, jag tänkte säga om man ligger på knappt en miljon första och sen 4,5 andra så är väl det 450 procent, det är väl inte skit.
Nej, det är inte skit men jag tyckte att jag var min terapeuta innan det här.
Och hon var såhär, du hån mot dig själv.
Man bara, ja, för att man känner att allting ligger på mig och det är det som jag försöker komma ifrån lite nu.
Vi håller på med vår nästa kapitalrunda och det är såhär, jag tänker inte köra allt lass själv nu.
Alltså nu måste jag våga släppa in någon annan i, som förmodligen kommer göra bättre än vad jag själv gör.
För det är såhär, jag måste bara släppa kontrollen.
Och det är det som är det svåra, jag har grova issues med det.
Alltså kontrollbehov.
Men det är det som måste göras nu, nu måste vi bara bli fler.
För jag känner att jag begränsar oss genom att vara själv.
Känner du en viss rädsla i att du måste växa fort?
För att på ett sätt behöver ni ett etablera, att det är vi som är the good guys här, så att inte någon kommer in och tar den platsen vi har etablerat.
Känner du att fan vi måste skala fort?
Ja, lite med det.
Att jag känner för sig, nej jag är inte jätterädd att någon kommer göra samma sak, för jag tror inte att jag står och väntar med blame-märken att komma in.
Just av anledningen att det är ganska svårt.
Så jag skulle nog inte säga det, men jag vill liksom, man är ny och man är en uppåtstickare, man är en utmanare, det kan du leva på ett tag.
Men du kan liksom inte alltid vara det här lilla bolaget och inte ta nästa kliv i att spela på riktigt.
Eller om du förstår vad jag menar, att jag vill inte bara vara ett litet företag länge för folk.
Utan så här, vi måste ta nästa steg.
Nej, det är du som vill bli vuxen.
Det är inte för att du har upplevt att kunderna...
Jag spelar ju fortfarande på att vi gör en liten start-up.
Ja men det är ni inte, jag tycker att ni står där.
Jag bara vinner att...
Är det din inställning?
Jag är rädd att kunderna ska tycka så här, Gud vad de står och gneter länge på samma ställe.
Nej det tror jag inte.
Vad tror du det?
Nej jag vet inte men man är ju liksom, nej det kanske bara jag själv.
Det är inte självvitt när folk slår från underläge, och ni slår verkligen från underläge.
Det är som du säger, det är en ultraetablerad bransch.
Och så kommer man utifrån.
Fan om ni omsatte 250 miljoner, är ni fortfarande lilla, lilla, lilla.
Ja jag vet, jag vet.
Alltså, vad då, om jag kollar på de här jättestora jättarna, tänker inte säga vem det är men de har omsatt i 137 miljarder.
Ja.
Alltså, och det här är då nästa grej.
De här bolagen, de, jag vet inte vad de håller på med, men de försöker ju förstöra för oss.
För de vill inte ha in någon till spelare.
Men du vet så här, vi får varningsbrev på varningsbrev och hot och liksom, de är så tuffa mot oss.
Men liksom, typ Sveriges vassaste advokater som liksom, de lägger säkert flera hundratusen på att de ska jobba mot oss.
Och jag väljer ju att svara dem själv.
Alltså för det är så här, de har ingenting att komma med.
Men det är fortfarande så här, hur kan de ens känna sig hotade av oss?
Alltså vi två.
Vi två tjejer som har ett bolag på en miljon.
Alltså varför lägger ni ens fokus på det?
Det är lite halvsjukt att man ens har en sökning på det.
Eller att någon ens noterar det.
Men vad är det som är, att du kanske inte får gå in på exakt?
Jo, det är ju inte hemligt.
Är det att du får inte kalla det blöja?
Nästan på den nivån.
De försöker ju.
Det är hur de liksom, de är inne i vår marknadsföring hela tiden och förvränger den kan jag tycka.
Att de sätter den i andra sammanhang.
Att de kopplar en mening som jag har sagt typ från draknästet.
Så slänger de in den på ett helt annat ställe.
De försöker bygga upp det som att vi använder vår marknadsföring fel.
Och att vi gör det svårt för deras produkter.
Och det är såhär, ja jag säger att vår blöja har bambu istället för plast.
Det är inte fel med det.
Alltså det är fakta.
Sen är det synd att de tar åt sig så mycket av att vara en plastblöja.
Eller liksom, ja de hade kunnat stå runt i det.
Det är det.
Sen är de på, vad ska jag säga mer, de är ju mer de...
Det är väl mest marknadsföringsbitar, hur vi kommunicerar, hur våra paket ser ut.
Vad är felet med hur paketen ser ut?
Jag har ju sett, ni har ju någon sorts, vad ska vi kalla det, kartongliknande.
Vi har innehållsförteckning, det gör inte de.
Är det på att man skiter i det eller?
Ja, för de går in på alla våra uspar.
Jag vet att vi har sagt att vi har tre gånger mindre plast på vårt, ett av våra paket, nu har vi sorgit bort det.
Men då är de så här, tre gånger mindre plast än vad?
Alltså vilken blöja har ni tagit?
Vilken storlek?
Det måste stå med vilken jämförelse ni har.
Och ni får inte göra jämförande marknadsföring, ni får inte säga att er blöja är hållbar, ni måste säga att den är hållbarare än det andra.
Men är inte det lite att slå ner sig själv, om du säger att vi har tre gånger mindre plast, och de säger att ni måste säga vilken blöja, här är du inte lite handys, du får bara skriva tre gånger mindre plast.
Ja det är den här.
Jo, det finns så många grejer som jag har velat göra mot dem, och gå tillbaka, men jag har bara valt att ha en strategi.
Att jag fokuserar på vår produkt, jag fokuserar på vårt brand.
Om det blir komplicerat för mig att säga så, okej då ändrar jag, då säger jag det på något annat sätt.
För tre gånger mindre plast egentligen, det säger inte kunden speciellt mycket.
Vad är det liksom, de gör mig bättre.
Varje gång jag får ett brev av dem så gör de mig bättre.
Och jag tycker att de har hjälpt mig.
Jag har blivit sjukt bra på mitt jobb, som är marknadsföring.
Alltså i vad man får säga, hur man får kommunicera.
Vi får vassare tonalitet i det vi säger.
Och så länge de fokuserar på att försvåra för oss, så fokuserar vi på att komma framåt.
För de lägger sin tid fel, de borde fokusera på att göra bättre och lägre.
Om man använder en sån här, det kallas väl inte hotbrev, det kallas väl någon sorts season-blablabla-brev.
Men får man använda det i marknadsföring?
Nej, tänk om du bara tog breven och så la du bara upp det i reklam.
Alltså jag har varit så sugen på det.
Jag har varit ganska kul.
Det är okej, det är inget hemligt med varningsbrit.
Det är ofentliga anlingar liksom.
Så det är ju bara att dela, vilket jag har sagt att jag kommer att göra om de fortsätter.
Så att liksom, om ni vill försöka förstöra för mig så gör det, men då kommer jag att göra det öppet.
Och det känns som en ganska kul grej för andra att skriva om.
Så att det är liksom, men jag är nog mer liksom chockad över att det såg ut så.
Alltså så här, att första gången jag fick mig ett varningsbrev då blev jag typ illamående.
Alltså det var tre dagar innan julafton, det är typ då de skickar dem också, innan julafton eller midsommar, då är vi typ, nu ska jag cyka ut henne typ.
Och de kommer med så grova hot, alltså så här, vi kommer stoppa din försäljning i alla den här butiker, du kommer tvingas dra in alla produkter, svara inom fem dagar på att du går med på den här dealen.
Alltså det är typ så.
Och det är så här, nu har jag haft turen och haft min pappa så att jag har kunnat ditt bollar de här grejerna med, och han är så här, det får jag inte svara, det är skit, de har ingenting.
Alltså jag menar att man själv blir rädd, när du får ett brev från en advokatbyrå, med liksom, de skriver ju på ett speciellt sätt.
Alltså jag tror att det var chocken i början, det tog jättemycket tid i början, och sen när jag fick dem andra också, blev man alltid lite så här, ah gud vad jobbigt.
Men nu känns det mest att det är jobbigt för att det tar mycket tid och påhöva svara dem.
Alltså, de tar tid för mig att göra något annat.
Och tack till Shadke PT nu som kan, så jag slipper lägga pengar på en advokat.
Men det är typ så seriöst vi tar dem just nu.
Är det fan vad sjukt.
Är du lite bitter på verkligheten?
Känner du bara, fan, var det så här världen såg ut?
Lite chockad faktiskt.
Inte bitter, men mer såhär, okej ni ska vara barnmärken.
Ni är stolthet för Sverige.
Och så håller ni på såhär.
Jag är besviken på det.
Och jag kan tycka att det är sjukt, jag kan tycka att det är sjukt att de kan känna sig hotade, och det är jag inte bitter på utan det är jag snart färdig om, det är jag glad för.
För då gör jag obviously något rätt, om de tycker att det är värt att lägga tiden på mig.
Men det enda som jag kanske tycker är bitter är att det är så jävla svårt att ta sig in på en, för att de är så tuffa just med allt som de gör.
Vi stängde ner engångsgrejer i Sverige.
Man får inte köpa vissa bestick och såhär, typ sugrör och sånt där, vilket jag pröver att hata för att fan skitsamma typ.
Men däremot så blöjer, återigen som du säger, man använder ju kopiösa mängder.
Och det är verkligen, om man inte har barn så tror jag inte man fattar vilka sjuka mängder det blöjer.
Det är verkligen absurda mängder det blöjer.
Och sen finns det hela vuxen blöjer, blöjer är ju väldigt väldigt mycket skräp.
Och bindor, naponger.
Alltså, ja.
Vad är det som gör att inte lagstiftning, jag ska inte försöka få det som ett svar som såhär, oh it's the bad guys, men har du reflekterat någon gång över kring lagstiftning och plast?
Jag satt faktiskt i en panel i Almedalen i somras.
Ihop med en politiker från Centerpartiet och några andra personer.
Och då tog jag faktiskt upp det som en grej.
För att jag tycker att, men inte just med plastprodukter, men generellt kring produkter som är hållbara och liksom ekoprodukter.
För det är väldigt dyrt för en familj att köpa det.
För det är samma typer av moms och så vidare.
Men de flesta som gör ekoprodukter, eller som kommer med en ny produkt som är mindre plast, som är mer medveten eller vad man ska säga.
Det är ju oftast en mindre leverantör.
Så de kan inte ta de priserna som de här jättarna kan.
Och då blir det, genom att det inte får resubventionerats på något sätt, eller att de varken hjälper företagen eller kunden att göra hållbara val, då blir det en klassfråga.
Och det är illa tycker jag.
Alltså det behöver bli en klassfråga om du nu vill göra medvetna val.
Och då tog jag upp det, det borde vara att det är lägre moms.
Alltså på de produkterna som försöker ta bort mer plast, de som försöker kanske ha mindre socker i saker.
Att de bolagen som faktiskt försöker göra skillnad på hälsoproblem, att man kan få hjälp.
Och då var de såhär, ja, de blev lite tysta och tyckte väl att det var bra idéer.
Men, så absolut.
Jag har tänkt på det.
Jag tycker att det är störigt och jag har varit uppe och pratat med regionerna.
I att liksom, det är för att upphandlingstiderna är så sjuklånga i Sverige.
Det är såhär, fem år sitter man på ett avtal.
Det är såhär, om fem år då är det...
Man har ingen aning om vad som händer om fem år.
Och om vi nu har en ny produkt som kan vara både liksom, nu ska jag vara försiktig med vad jag säger om någon lyssnar men, bättre för miljön.
Att vi tycker att den är det för att den är växtbaserad.
Ja, då är det liksom, då kanske man borde få hjälp på traven istället för att behöva vänta ut tre år till.
Alltså innan man får chansen att vara med.
Så det finns absolut grejer man kan göra och behöver hjälp.
Alltså från politiskt håll, absolut.
Vilka är det som köper?
För du tog ju fram produkten för allergi eller exem och liknande.
Men nu snackar vi plast och någon slags hållbarhetsgrej.
Vilka är era kunder till största del?
Är det allergifolket eller?
Nej, jag skulle inte säga att det är någon speciell kundså inom allergi eller hållbarhet, utan jag tror mest att det har varit mycket till folk som gillar att prova nytt.
Den kunden som tycker att det är roligt att testa nya produkter.
Sen tror jag att det är många, nu märker vi när vi är ett lite mer etablerat varumärke, att första gången föräldrar köper våra produkter.
För att de vet att de kan köpa faktiskt.
Att man gör jättemycket research till vad man ska ha, och nu börjar det ändå komma upp när man googlar vilka blöjor, bra blöjor, då kommer Babis med där.
Och då läser de på vad skillnaden är, och då är det många som beställer våra blöjor.
Sen tror jag att med andra barnet, man är ju lite mer skitsamma.
Den får ha.
Eller så var vi i alla fall, nu hade vi våra blöjor såklart.
Men med andra grejer, du kan erva de kläderna, dina skor kan vara en storlek för stora.
Du kan tugga på sten.
Exakt, alltså det är så här, gör det.
Men med första barnet är man mer noggrann.
Så den målgruppen blir väldigt viktiga.
Och där blir det också då när vårt nya varumärke BAM kommer in som vi lanserade igår.
Just med troskydd, bindor och tamponger.
Där tänker vi att vi kan nå kvinnorna i ett mycket tidigare skede.
Och gillar de produkterna då så kommer det att bli lättare övergång att gå till BAM i.
Så vi såg liksom i valet och kvalet att, för det tipset fick jag faktiskt av Region Stockholm.
En kvinna är mest mottaglig för information om graviditet och blöjor och så.
Mellan vecka 16 och vecka 25 då tar de in mycket information.
Efter vecka 25 så förbereder de sig mest för förlossning.
De börjar liksom tänka mycket på bebisen och man börjar bli tung och så vidare.
Men under den här tiden då, så där kan man mata kvinnan med information.
Så antingen lägger ni massa pengar på marknadsföring för gravidan mellan de här veckorna, eller så tänker ni på produkter som ni kan få ut till de här kvinnorna innan.
Och då är det såhär, ja okej men jag hade länge tänkt på att göra bindor och tamponger för jag tycker att det är exakt samma grej egentligen som med blejer.
Ni kände att ni ville slåss mot fler stora konjunkturer?
Ja det är ju samma jättar men i fler kategorier.
Vi tänker såhär, vi tar dem från alla håll och kanter.
Det är populärt ja.
Det var liksom det vi kände att då ger vi oss in där.
Det var hur häftigt som helst för när jag började bolla det här med Ica och Coop att vi har sådana här produkter på G och de var absolut inte färdiga.
Då var de såhär när kommer de?
Snart.
Men det har inte kommit in på hemsidan än?
Nej vi har en egen hemsida till den.
Okej, okej.
Det heter Bam by bammies.com.
Men vi säljer inte produkterna ännu för vi har inte fått hitta med ännu.
Och vi lanserar dem, vi lanserade dem i går och började prata om det, men vi lanserar Ica butiker 8 september.
Fan vad coolt.
Så där tänker vi att det blir en väg in att nå kvinnor och få dem att bräda vår kundgrupp.
Är det inte lite kaxigt att dra in en helt ny kategori, år tre när man redan, ni har ju ganska mycket kvar att växa inom blöjer, det är inte så att ni är färdiga utan...
Nej, absolut det var många typer investerare.
Vem kom på den idén?
Det var jag.
Och jag tänkte nog inte att det blir dubbelt så mycket jobb heller.
Att nu blir det ett nytt varumärke, det är väl exakt samma grejer med det här märket som för Bambis.
Det blir bara dubbelt så mycket.
Men vet du vad jag kände där?
Jag kände att den här kategorin, jag måste ta den platsen.
För gör ingen annan det, eller gör inte jag det, så kommer någon annan komma och ta den.
För det här är för obvious och det är för sjukt att det inte finns fler kategorier här.
Framförallt när kvinnohälsa och hormonhälsa och allt sånt där börjar jag komma verkligen upp på tapeten.
Det känns som att vi har så bra relationer med Ica, Coop, Mathem, alla återförsäljare.
Jag är de typ mera, vi är best buddies med dem.
Så det känns som att jag sitter i ett läge där jag kan få ut det.
Distributionen är så sjukt viktig på de här produkterna att få finnas i dagligvaruhandeln.
Det är många som har provat att ha bara med e-handel, det funkar inte.
För de här produkterna är produkter som du fortfarande köper i din matbutik.
Där har jag pratat med andra som har gjort det här innan, att som då gått i konkurs, de bolagen, intervjuade ju dem innan för att vara så här, varför har det inte funkat för er?
Och då var det många som, båda bolagen som har gått i konkurs sa att det är för att vi inte fick plats i dagligvaruhandeln.
De tog inte in våra produkter.
Och nu satt jag i ett läge där ICA frågade när kommer leveransen?
Och då fick vi ju bara gasa på och se till att det skulle komma.
Och då tog de in dem direkt.
Det var faktiskt sjukt för mig.
För annars hade man ju behövt, de sa det själva, vanligtvis behöver du 150 butiker innan du blir centrala listad.
Så enjoy.
Hur ser, du har tagit in lite olika investerare här i det här gänget.
Vad är det för folk som har hoppat på den här resan?
Det är faktiskt lite olika personer.
I början var det en del familj som, det var gulligt för det var liksom innan jag ens tänkte på det så såg de bara, de märkte väldigt mycket jobba och var såhär, om du vill investera någon gång, så är det till för att vi vill vara med.
De fick såklart vara med och sen så var de här Feminvest affärsänglarna.
Och då valde jag på kompetenser lite, vad de har gjort innan.
Jag fick med en tjej som hade gjort en exit innan och visste väldigt lite hur det var att vara egenföretagare och byggbolag och så.
Och sen en annan tjej som hade jobbat inom förlossningsvården och jobbat mycket mer med public affairs, bra kontaktnät.
En annan tjej som höll på att bygga egna bolag men i USA.
Och sen, alla har lite speciella områden.
Men sen så tog vi inte in så mycket pengar och de fick en ganska liten andel för att de är med i bolaget.
Och sen, det här var faktiskt väldigt kul för att min mamma, och jag vi pratar väldigt mycket, är operationsköterska.
Jag bor på sjukhus och då har hon stått och babblat om mig eftersom jag ringer henne tio gånger per dag, så hon berättat någonting.
Så hon berättat väldigt mycket om vårt bolag, för sina kollegor.
Och sen då var det väl en sjukköterska där som också hade snappat upp det och sen gått hem och presenterat det för sin man.
Att såhär, nu ska de ta in pengar, hörde jag.
Och jag tycker att det verkar som ett coolt bolag och då träffade jag dem för att de var intresserade.
Och sen blev de en av de största de som gick in med mest.
För att han hade också jobbat med ett annat bolag inom Blöjer och kände väl att såhär, han har lite att kunna hjälpa till med, han är bra på att bygga e-handel och är liksom ett bra ballplack.
Så det var kul.
De har liksom kommit på lite, ja, de har kommit in bara.
Vad tror du folk går igång på som investerar?
Är det liksom underdog-fighten eller är det att man gillar dig eller är det att man gillar, ja men, Blöjer behöver ändra.
Har alla barn liksom, är de såhär, jag bara, ofta ska man gå igång på.
Vissa har stora barn, eller de flesta skulle jag säga har äldre barn.
För att de här är lite äldre än vad jag är.
Jag tror att det de går igång på är typ att jag inte kan ta ett nej, och det tror jag att de har märkt att jag gör typ vad som helst, alltså för att det här ska funka.
Så det är väl tryggt tror jag de tänker.
De har sett att det är ganska skalbart, i och med att jag har varit en person som har liksom tagit det hittills.
Jag tror att de ser att det är en produkt som förr eller senare kommer det behövas göras någon skillnad på det.
Det kommer inte få fortsätta så som det har gjort hittills.
Men sen också kanske att de ser att det är en marknad där man ser att konsumenten börjar bli mer och mer medveten och söka efter sådana här alternativ.
Jag tycker bara att man ser det på de unga personerna idag.
Om vi kollar de som är 15-16.
De är så mycket mer pålästa än vad man själv var och får nyheter till sig på ett annat sätt.
De kan läsa på mycket lättare.
De blir pumpade med information hela tiden.
Så jag tror att det kommer en generation nu som kommer att komma upp som kommer att ställa högre krav.
Du har ju vuxit ganska fort, även om du tycker att du borde växa ännu mer, men det är ju en snabb tillväxt.
Vad är det som håller tillbaka?
Skalning, var är det flaskhalsarna nu?
I nästa steg, vad är det som blir knepigt?
Om jag bara, vad jag tänker på själv, tycker att det tar för lång tid, så är det för att jag tycker att marknaden börjar bli redan, men att det är fortfarande inte helt redo.
Jag tänker att det är en grej, men sen så är det också att det som håller tillbaka mig är priset.
Jag hade gärna sagt ett lägre pris på våra blöjor.
Det är ett sånt priskrig därefter.
Är det det som, är det, är det...
Jag tror att det stoppar folk från, jag tror att det stoppar folk från att prova första gången.
För jag tror att såhär, det är fajn om du köper en bar.
Det är liksom, du plockar den när du är på väg ut till butiken.
Det är fem, om det kostar fem kronor mer då eller inte, det spelar typ ingen roll.
Men blöjor som ändå, jag tror föräldrar tycker att blöjor är dyrt.
Som det är.
Det är dyrt men det finns ju, om man går in, vi undviker hela tiden här att säga namn på olika blöjor, men om man går in på affären så vet man att det finns typ tre olika.
Och då finns det två stycken och så finns det en som finns där.
Och så, då kostar de lite olika, men ganska ofta har man ju en favorit och den väljer man.
Ibland kostar den lite mer och ibland lite mindre, men man tar ju ändå den.
Är man verkligen så, jag fattar vad du menar, jag bara funderar på, kan inte det vara lite positivt att man ligger i det?
Det är absolut positivt när man får in kunden.
Men jag tror i det läget som vi är just nu, när man fortfarande är ett litet bolag och kollar på att bygga upp, vi är inte ett varumärke som folk känner till.
Att trösken att prova är liksom, hade vi kostat mindre så hade ju trösken varit lägre.
Då hade de känt att de är billigare än de andra blöderna.
Då klarar jag att prova.
Jag kanske kan tjäna pengar på att byta.
Då hade det varit ytterligare en usp för att byta.
Det är väl en plastkals.
Sen skulle jag säga att det är...
Jag vet inte.
Men har ni räknat på det?
Om ni tillverkar 15 gånger mer, kommer ni komma ner då i pris?
Det är volymspelet.
Det handlar om att vi måste komma över den första nivån.
Vi är inte så långt ifrån det nu.
Men vi måste palla den här sista biten innan vi kan gasa på ordentligt.
Jag tycker att vi är på en jättegott väg.
För det är så som vi syns just nu i sociala medier och hur folk väljer att dela av oss utan att vi betalar för det för att de faktiskt på riktigt tycker att det är bra.
På liksom Bamse till exempel, alltså Merk varumärket Bamse, de skrev till oss att de vill ta fram en blöja.
Och de hade gjort något liknande i Finland och då tänkte de ju på oss att vi borde göra en blöja ihop.
Och det för mig var såhär, du vet jag såg i skitbacken med mina barn och fick höra Bamse hittar fram en blöja hos.
För mig var det såhär, det är så extremt stort för mig.
För att Bamse är ju liksom världens snällaste björn.
Nej men det är ett väldigt känt brand.
Så jag tror att liksom vi har samarbetet med UNICEF och jag tror att det liksom ihop med alla partner som faktiskt jobbar med oss och vill att det ska gå bra för oss, så kommer vi komma dit.
Så jag tror inte att det är så jättemycket flaskhälsa just nu.
Jag skulle säga att det kanske är mitt psyke som är en flaskhälsa också.
Att man vill det så mycket så att det liksom det tar överenslut, men det gör det ju för alla entreprenörer kanske.
Men jag tror att det är därför jag också går mycket i terapin nu för att bara lära mig, hur ska jag hantera de här känslorna och tankarna och hur ska jag liksom göra bra actions av det istället?
För att det får ta över.
Fan, jag tror att jag stannar av där.
Det är en coolt jävla spännande resa att vara podd.
Att blöja kunde vara spännande.
Nej, det är det.
Men ett stort tack för att du var med i podden Filippa.
Tack själv.
Lycka till.
Tack.
Sen tror jag att med andra barnet, man är ju lite mer skötsamma.
Den får ha.
Eller så har vi i alla fall.
Men det hade vi i våra blädd såklart.
Men med andra grejer bara.
Du kan ärva de kläderna, dina skor kan vara en storlek för stora.
Du kan tugga på sten, absolut.